Let's take a brief
look at how to think
about submitting your
photographs as potential cover
art in their presentations.
The first thing
that's essential is
for you to study
the journal layout
to which you are
submitting your image,
how they might be placed in
a particular cover format.
Most covers these
days are full bleeds.
That is, the image
takes up the whole cover
and is therefore vertical.
Some of them still have,
let's say, rectangle places
within the larger
vertical format.
But most of them are
bleeds at this point.
So you have to think
about that when you
do submit an idea for a cover.
Think about where the
journal's logo is placed,
where additional text
might be dropped.
You have to take all these
things into consideration
to help the art director decide
whether or not the image is
good enough for a cover.
But I do suggest not submitting
a cover idea with the journal
logo.
Just let the folks at the
journal use their imaginations.
Let's start with something
I did fairly recently.
Here I was given a number
of samples of material.
They're all fabricated pieces
that respond differently
to pressure.
Trying to think of
how in the world
I was going to come up with
an interesting cover design.
So I decided to play
around with the shapes.
Here I'm using my
flatbed scanner,
and I'm adding a few
pieces here and there
and finally wound up with
this composition, which
I thought had the potential
of being considered
for this particular
journal cover.
And I did digitally add a
gradient to the background,
as you can see.
In the end, yes, it did make
a cover, which is always nice.
But do keep in mind,
it's not just the image
that will get you on the cover.
It's the science in the article
that informs the journal's
selection, maybe some
other things as well,
which none of us are privy to.
So it's not just the
aesthetics, mostly about
the importance of the research,
which should be the case.
Here's another example,
which you've seen before,
showing the flexible circuitry
imprinted on transparent
material.
And again, we were delighted to
get the cover of the journal,
probably because of the
importance of the science.
And by the way, that journal
now has another format,
where the cover art takes a
completely different shape
than what you're seeing here.
So again, it's very important
to match your image's format
with the journal's format.
For this image, another one
that you've seen before,
it still is one of my favorites
after all these years,
a bit unusual because I
don't usually like old stuff.
But they used it for the cover
of a textbook in chemistry.
After all, this is very,
very much about chemistry.
And notice how they cropped
the image to fit the format.
And of course, I gave
the publisher permission
to do that.
And here, this image was made
by the researchers hundreds
of miles from my studio.
But we communicated closely
through email with my making
suggestions on how to
photograph and light the work.
In this next image, the
researchers shined a laser
onto the container with
no additional room light,
and we see new
material showing up.
We couldn't see it before
because those balls have
the same index of refraction
as the solution in which they
were floating.
That's the point
of this research.
The researchers wanted
to show this image
with a hand in place, suggesting
that the laser is turned off
ready to be turned on.
And I said, no,
please, no hands.
I believe that hands
generally distract and detract
from the rest of the image.
It's just another distraction.
Please don't use hands.
So I suggested starting with
the container under a lamp
as before and then
take another picture
with just the laser
shining through the lower
part of the image to
see the hidden material.
So this is the first image,
and this is the second image.
I selected the lower part of
the second image, copied it
and pasted it onto
the first image.
So that we have a sort of photo
illustration, which you're
going to see more of next week,
in that we will show what it is
without the laser and what it
is with the laser side by side
comparing the two with the
information in the caption.
The idea was to make the cover,
and we did, which was nice.
I think it worked well.
You know, some images
look even better
when they are made into covers
with the addition of text.
They might not be
spectacular on their own,
but often, in my opinion, are
enhanced with well-placed text,
as what happens here.
This is not a very
exciting image that I made.
It's a detail of
equipment that's
used in this particular lab.
I was delighted that they
liked the abstract quality
of the image and used
it well, in fact,
with good placement of text.
In this image, I was working
on some print material
for what was then called the
DuPont MIT Alliance, which
funded research about
bioinspired material.
I made a picture of a
sea urchin, which is
a fascinating story in itself.
I made it straight on.
I also tried it with
the flatbed scanner.
In the end, the very
talented graphic designer,
he created a pretty stunning
brochure, placed the scanner
image on the cover,
and it worked well
in terms of the whole
design of the brochure.
And in this image,
which was also
part of the same
project, a bioreactor
where liver cells grow in
three-dimensional space,
I did like the
picture as I made it.
But once again, the
graphic designer
took it to another level,
using the image as is
and also associating it
on the page with a drawing
of the same reactor.
A very interesting way of
reinforcing the structure.
For our book No Small Matter,
I made a photograph of beer.
The idea was to consider the
molecular or nanostructure
of bubbles.
Now, notice that I
included the wall
of the rectangular container
in the image on the right.
The final cover wrapped the
image around the full book
and used the container area
as the front book flap,
which I think is kind of cool.
Here's an image
you've seen before,
and here it's used in the title
page of the Chinese version
of our book No Small Matter.
And here's the American title
page, again just showing you
how photographs can
be used with text.
Once again, dropping
text, I think,
can make an OK image,
(which this is, of bubbles),
into a more interesting cover.
The left side is the back
cover of this booklet.
I think that worked pretty well.
And this photograph is a
straight, highly documentary
image showing the presence
of material in an assay.
And I simply used the image
in a more expanded idea
for a cover illustratively
giving more information
about the material.
I don't use Illustrator very
often, but in this case,
it seemed to work.
And finally, here's
another image
you've seen before,
used both as a cover
and back cover for
an MIT publication.
I was quite pleased that the
image I made 15 years ago still
had a life, frankly because of
the importance of nanocrystal,
or quantum dot science.
Yeah, the picture was good,
but the science is even better.
If you are lucky to work
with researchers whose work
is timeless, then
your photographs
might become timeless as
well, if you are lucky.